the other thing that i have to tell you
i enjoyed watching this weekend and
usually i don't enjoy this
donald trump glitched
very badly causing psychiatric nurses to
email me and to say david
i'm recognizing what's going on with
trump uh so this is this this is this is
pretty serious
um donald trump was scheduled to have a
rally in nebraska on friday evening
there were big storms and so the rally
was postponed until yesterday sunday
and donald trump
truly seemed to have completely lost his
wits he didn't seem to know what was
going on this was a nearly two hour long
it was like a sprawling almost fidel
castro like droning on about nothing
nearly two hours of this stuff
the crowd was as bored as ever and trump
continued to have these brain glitches
making no sense just like
swiss cheese you know mayonnaise is up
there in his skull
my absolute favorite moment and i
tweeted about this right away and it
started trending on twitter and then the
clip ultimately getting millions of
views
trump didn't know who he who he had
endorsed
trump claimed that he endorsed
a non-existent candidate
blending the names of two different
candidates and looking off to the side
saying who did we endorse
this is an incredible moment take a look
at this that's what they're waiting for
they're waiting for one race you know
we've endorsed dr oz we've endorsed
jp right j.d mandel and he's doing great
[Laughter]
so let let me back that up first he says
we've endorsed jp right and he looks
over to the side jp i don't know who's
jp he says we've endorsed j.d mandel now
this is a blend of two people who are
running against each other in the ohio
republican senate primary jd vance is
one candidate and josh mandel is another
candidate now it's not just that trump
doesn't know who the hell he endorsed
and he makes up a name of a person that
doesn't exist mandel spent the entire
election cycle trying to get trump's
endorsement he didn't get it
trump goes to jd vance jd vance
basically threw himself at the altar of
trump and said anything he could
apologized for the criticisms of trump
from years ago in order to finally get
trump's endorsement
and then trump ends up mentioning his
opponent trump ends up mentioning the
guy he's running against by saying j.d
mandel two days before the primary he
confuses who he even endorsed if biden
did this they'd be saying oh we got to
remove him for the 25th amendment he's
demented
he's got dementia he can't think after
seeing this i got an email from a nurse
educator who also worked as an aged care
registered nurse
and said this is a quote from from her
i cared for people with dementia for
many years and and know a lot about it
trump demonstrates a telling symptom of
dementia called perseverance he says the
same phrases over and over again
everyone knows it's more than has ever
happened before and it's really a shame
he uses the same gestures over and over
again pointing upward
making the circle with the thumb and
forefinger he tells the same stories
over and over again he seems unable to
grasp and repeat news stories in this
case this is new stuff right jd mandel
this is these are new candidates doesn't
know what's going on he uses simple
language with restricted vocabulary he
pads his language with unnecessary
phrases
he can't speak specifically only in
generalities no one can diagnose
dementia with certainty in this way but
it doesn't look good
um by the way this jd mandelgaf
hasn't appeared on truth social it
hasn't appeared on getter the users on
parlor aren't talking about it fox news
isn't talking about it they'll never
even know that it happened um it
actually it's almost like that time when
trump got obama's name wrong obama you
guys remember that okay so um then just
glitch after glitch after glitch we
there was no actual substance to the
rally so i won't even bore you with it
but then at another point trump glitched
on mitt romney's name and you can see
that he kind of has this twitch when he
does it even though it was totally made
up that was about a guy named a rhino
named mitt romney
it's almost quite literally like
someone's stopping a record mit rhyme
mitt romney
mitt romney
listen to it once even though it was
totally made up that was about a guy
named a rhino named mitt romney
mitt romney that
is really quite a noise um and then
lastly trying to talk about billy the
kid
i guess talking about billy the kids
bovine counterpart billy the cud this
one is wacky
i've had more investigations than jesse
james billy they could
you really don't know whether to laugh
or cry but this is a guy who seems very
unwell and it's a combination of
weaponized narcissism
it's i don't know what else you know
fidel castro was known castro was known
for four five hour speeches
trump
two hours of trump is as bad as five of
castro i would argue just endlessly
going over a lot of the same stuff crowd
visibly bored
uh and then the glitches the glitches
are just coming so frequently so what's
going on with them i don't know but even
trump now is saying you know it's
possible that health might be a reason i
don't run in 2024.
who knows we're going to keep following
it and again for all the people saying
biden doesn't look good if you look at
biden at the white house correspondents
dinner this weekend and you look at
trump talking about j.d mandel a quite
literally imaginary person
seems pretty clear to me which one's
worse off we'll take a quick break and
be back right after this
do you know the fastest growing crime in
the united states for years the rate of
this crime has been surging the crime is
identity theft and it happens way more
often than you might think
it's happened to me i've talked about
this on the show before and it can be
really bad sometimes you get a text that
your email password has been changed
your bank calls about unusual activity
your paypal account is getting drained
and it can happen very very quickly to
keep my accounts protected i use aura
our sponsor aura is identity theft
protection
fraud monitoring and password management
all wrapped into one aura monitors the
dark web for your information they
monitor your credit card they monitor
your bank accounts
my subscription to aura gives me peace
of mind protects my devices it protects
all of my different accounts and i can
monitor everything in one place on the
app if i get attacked aura actually
takes action to prevent and resolve the
issues in real time and aura is letting
my audience try it completely free for
14 days go to aura.com
pacman the link is down below